so representative eric swalwell has
filed suit against former president
donald trump for
basically inciting a riot he has filed a
civil suit to try and get damages for
all of the things that he claims that
president trump did as a result of
january
6th now this lawsuit is not on great
footing and is probably going to get
dismissed for several different reasons
first
presidents have absolute immunity from
all civil actions taken as a result
of official acts while president the
case law is pretty much settled on this
point you
cannot civilly sue a former president
for actions they took with it were
part of their official duties it appears
that a prosecutor could go after a
former president for
criminal actions taken but not a civil
suit and additionally this lawsuit would
have to get over the hurdle to prove
that
president trump committed incitement
that his words were not protected by the
first amendment
and that is likely to be dispositive as
well so this lawsuit is probably
not going anywhere so if you're eric
schwabel i won't see you in court but if
you don't subscribe i will see you
in court